Speaker 1: Welcome to the show, everybody.
There they are doing it.
They've done it.
They are actually voting for the government
to shut down and for the United States to
default on its debt and for the paychecks
to start being withheld from so many government
workers.
I'm talking about Republicans.
Of course, this is not exactly winning.
This is not exactly America first.
And what we have to remember as we go through
this story and go through the facts is that
they want chaos.
They are taking this sort of acceleration
is burn it down approach when it comes to
Democrats currently having the White House
and having the Senate and having the House.
Let's take a look at what's going on.
And, of course, it's now Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell, who is orchestrating all
of it.
Mitch McConnell, Senate Republican, has voted
for the United States to default on its debt
and for the government to shut down.
They're doing it again.
And we're going we're going to look at the
history of this and you will see that this
is another one of those reckless political
footballs.
But this time only one side is even playing
the game.
We often talk about debt and deficit.
The football is thrown back and forth.
Democrats and Republicans both play the game,
although it's Republicans who don't actually
care about debt and deficit.
In this case, it's it's a football that Republicans
are only tossing back and forth between themselves.
Business Insider reporting Senate Republicans
led by Minority Leader Mitch McConnell, blocked
a measure on Monday evening that would have
averted both a debt default and a government
shutdown, bringing the US another step closer
to a financial debacle as Republicans escalate
their efforts to derail President Joe Biden's
domestic agenda.
All 50 Republican senators voted against the
House approved legislation that funds the
government through December third and suspends
the debt ceiling until the end of next year,
heightening the brinksmanship over the federal
government's ability to pay its bills.
That has roiled Congress for months.
The measure also includes twenty eight billion
dollars in disaster aid funding for communities
ravaged by a recent pair of hurricanes, along
with the aid to resettle Afghan refugees in
the United States.
The vote was 48 to 50, and the bill failed
to clear the 60 vote threshold to end debate
known as the filibuster.
After the vote, Majority Leader Schumer assailed
Senate Republicans, saying they, quote, voted
to drive our country straight to a government
shutdown and the first default in the country's
history.
Now, do we think the U.S. really is ultimately
going to default on its debt?
No.
No, and that's why I actually think oftentimes
I think the adjectives and descriptions in
articles are are very wrong, but brinksmanship
sort of is accurate here.
In this particular case, the article notes
McConnell has insisted since June that Republicans
will not sign on to a debt limit hike or an
increase of how much the U.S. government can
pay back its bills.
Even as he said earlier this month, it was
a necessary step because America must never
default.
Wait.
If he said America must never default, why
is he voting in that way?
Now, what you have to understand and remember
is that they want chaos.
They basically want to at least make it seem
as though they are willing to burn it down,
although in the end, I don't believe they
are actually willing to do that.
They'll blame it on Democrats.
They'll say, oh, Democrats failed to negotiate
a bipartisan deal.
This is often what they do.
They pulled it with the Biden covid package,
even though with the Trump packages, it was
like, yeah, OK, basically do whatever you
want.
They are counting on, I guess, enough Republicans
and independents getting upset and saying,
wow, things went wrong.
It must be the party in power to blame.
Right.
And the sad part is to a great degree, that's
exactly how it might play out.
Smart independents would realize this is Republicans
sabotaging the economy or at least coming
close to sabotaging the economy to hurt Democrats.
It's extraordinarily reckless and it's all
to make Joe Biden look bad and to make other
Democrats look bad.
McConnell is not bluffing in the sense that
he really wants it to appear as though the
U.S. will default on its debt.
Ultimately, I don't think they will do it,
but they want to divert attention away from
the damage done by Trump.
They want to divert attention away from the
fact that more and more evidence is coming
out, that the, you know, maybe premeditated
is not an all encompassing term, but that
the January 6th riots, at least connected
to all sorts of different participants in
the Republican Party who wanted to create
as much chaos as possible when it came to
the election of Joe Biden.
And as I said at the top of the segment, this
debt ceiling stuff is really all Republicans
like it.
It's not really a political football in so
far as it's one side that plays this game,
much like with covid stimulus.
Let's talk covid stimulus first.
Trump does covid stimulus one.
Democrats have some comments.
They have some slight disagreements.
They're worried that the implementation of
some of the programs will essentially be a
slush fund, which they were right about because
that's exactly the way it was.
But they weren't saying, no, no, no, we're
not giving aid because a Republican is in
the White House.
Democrats did covid package one and then they
did covid package.
Two Republicans said this is the patriotic
thing to do.
This is the right thing to do.
Some of them are a little concerned with the
exact sticker price Joe Biden takes over,
says, well, it's time for the third covid
stimulus.
We're not out of this thing.
We need to do something.
And Republicans all of a sudden say, oh, this
this is too expensive and these provisions
are giving money to undocumented immigrants.
The provisions were no different than the
provisions under Trump covid Package one and
Trump covid Package two.
And it was Republicans who did the 180 based
on who was in power.
Go back to October of 2015.
In October of twenty fifteen Senate Republicans
under the leadership of Mitch McConnell, majority
leader at the time, voted to suspend the debt
ceiling for two years.
They suspended the debt ceiling September
of twenty seventeen Senate Republicans, under
the leadership of the majority leader Mitch
McConnell, voted to suspend the debt ceiling.
Again, that got us to August of twenty nineteen.
And Senate Republicans, under the leadership
of the majority leader, Mitch McConnell, voted
to suspend the debt ceiling for two years.
And now in September of twenty twenty one,
now it's Minority Leader Mitch McConnell.
Same situation.
Minority Leader Mitch McConnell is blocking
the Democratic majority 50/50 with Kamala
Harris.
Is the tie breaking vote except one?
You need 60, right.
But it isn't technically a Democratic majority.
Now, all of a sudden, that very same Republican
Party under the leadership of the exact same
guy, Mitch McConnell said, oh, no, no, no,
no, no, we can't we can't suspend the debt
ceiling.
We're going to go forward with default and
with a government shutdown.
These people are pathetic.
They really are.
And when Democrats and Republicans are the
same or basically the same, we talk about
it.
When they are dramatically different, we talk
about it.
And this is exactly.
One of those cases, ultimately, the debt ceiling,
I believe, will be raised and the U.S. is
not going to default on its debts eventually,
but the damage that will be done getting to
that and the embarrassment that will be will
be suffered, getting to that appears like
it will be pretty significant.